tremendous watch it just breaking down
this guy's game on Phil here's LeBron
James with the fall away and he buries
it LeBron 25 points per game on the year
about his body man he can just go
anywhere he wants to coach on the floor
and right there he's not seeing a crowd
at all just isolate you are so happy
they took a mid-range fadeaway McGee
with the great block LeBron in
transition James layup with the left
hand and then as you mentioned Jimmy on
the rummies
used to scout right for the Seattle
SuperSonics to me what was it like as a
James gets to the bucket ending at eight
nothing run presentable fifth game back
from injury missed about three weeks
with the left ankle injury James forcing
the turnover and running the floor
lobbing it for Davis for the stop know
when to be serious and when not there's
some fools in our league who are always
just clowning around
right but the great ones they know time
and place see the numbers for James six
points four assists 3 rebounds his 11
triple doubles on the year tied for
second with Yogesh one behind dont't as
James thrills a 349 in this quarter so
yeah they were doing a good job
Denver bench 7 of 10 from the floor
Anthony Davis gets the basket there 10
point Denver leaves those turnovers in
the last 12 minutes by the Nuggets
here's Davis on the low block takes it
to the rim and stuffs it can't let the
baseline be given up the helps come from
up top moves on that's a that's an
equal-opportunity program at Kentucky
and they work like pros he coaches and
like pros he hard coaches him
you know I think Calipari and Mike
sous-chef you both say they've had the
chance to coach the best of the one and
does for the most part beautiful
basketball I mean the pocket pass
delivered at this specific time and the
hands of 15 in white are tremendous most
Bible player in that national
championship game and he made one shot
is ten points per game Harris lowest
scoring average since his rookie year
six seasons ago here's James five on the
shot clock hits the jumper over grant
four seconds to go
LeBron wants it drives at two men foul
why he is who he is this gets in the
slot and nothing is gonna keep him from
getting where he wants to go the hips
are open up a little bit on the on-ball
defender physical presence of howard
against yo coach James driving in sleep
Ginga he may have just broke the rim
fanta caught by Chambers Kent was too
hard well for the players acting like
running on the court on the dunk
Stephens gonna be a little too intense I
think for that game I'm Gone with the
Wilbon squad I always wanted to be a
professional basketball player he's a
good player
Davis slams down the beautiful pass by
Rondo may have gotten away with an
offensive foul no call had James with
his eighth rebound he's now two boards
and one assist shy of a triple double
he's fouled here
whosh physicality we saw these big
shoulders without a shirt on about 10
o'clock this morning again the most
feared thing in this league I think is
this guy coming downhill at you and you
are not gonna bump him off of the path
that he wants to get to just tremendous
athlete now in a seventh season out of
Georgia third with the Lakers James
forces a turnover
caldwell-pope to the bride Millsaps
gonna let him go chase soars to the rim
and pushes a hot hands of LeBron James
and coach Whitman when he's on
defensively he's a monster
yokas at the scorer's table here's
Anthony Davis sizing it up from long
range his first three of the night
Murray running the floor driving at
Davis
wild shot wouldn't go James waiting for
it down on the other end
[Applause]
with three to go
least that should be option age James
driving on two defenders but it doesn't
matter LeBron gifts to the cop as 28 now
and make him kick it to Caruso James
long to not there gets his own miss goes
right back to the rim and a tip by
Anthony Davis gives the Lakers a
two-point lead beautiful part of the
game LeBron James no one boxes him off
he just goes and gets it I switch on
James he's got yoga John with a shot
clock at five and he loves the three in
this situation and steady drives gets
past yo gets late but the left hand is
good LeBron James with a 30 point night
Yogesh with the ball in the middle floor
is a problem
James Wow one shot with his back to the
rim by the time he released the ball
missed the shot but then Denver gives it
right back with a turnover Anthony Davis
wide open look and he closed home the
three
drive-in pick Anthony Davis three right
in front of the Denver bench
back-to-back triples by 80